more than 60 women have accused Bill
Cosby of drugging and sexually
assaulting them attorney Gloria Allred
represents 33 of the accusers and after
a jury convicted comedian yesterday all
right said a court of law finally
believed women Bill Cosby three words
for you guilty guilty three of all Reds
clients testified at Cosby's retrial
Gloria Allred joins us at the table
good to see missus already - good
morning Gail so I heard you say briefly
paraphrasing you said this is one of the
happiest days in your career yes were
you surprised by the verdict I was very
surprised and shocked by the verdict why
well because first of all the first
criminal trial the jury deadlocked
secondly it's a very high burden of
proof guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
and in the case of a celebrity who's on
trial such as mr. Cosby sometimes jurors
feel they need even more proof than
beyond a reasonable doubt sometimes they
feel they need it right up here to a
virtual certainty which is not the law
what made it different this time I think
what was different was in fact the court
allowed five prior bad act witnesses to
testify in the first trial even though
the prosecution asked the court to allow
it to put on 13 other accusers prior bad
act witnesses court only allowed one the
defense of course wanted no prior bad
act witnesses this time the same judge
decided okay this time five other
accusers can testify I saw there was
very vigorous cross-examination frankly
it was a smear campaign waged against
all of the accusers trying to discredit
them try to challenge them they held
their own I was very very proud of them
Gloria another thing that's different a
year later is the me2 movement that's
sweeping yes this country how much of an
impact did that have well I do think
Nora that it had some impact in the
sense that women are now being believed
in
numbers but of course even though more
than a half-million maybe it's up to a
million now have gone on hashtag me too
on the internet and told what they say
is the truth about their lives the abuse
that they've suffered the rape the
sexual assault the child sexual abuse
still on the Internet of course there
are no rules there are no standards and
and really there is no due process for
anybody you said now in a court of law
there's strict rules people are under
oath they have to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth so
help them God he made one last point in
your press conference yesterday and you
said how many women does it take for one
woman to be believed over the denial of
a rich powerful famous man and in this
case it took six the five other accusers
plus the very brave Audria constant and
I want to also give credit to my 33
accuses of mr. Cosby who came forward
and the court of public opinion at first
they were not believed but as more and
more women came forward the public began
to say wait there's something going on
here and of course mr. Cosby's lawyer
says the fights not over he's going to
appeal what do you think about that well
John of course he's going to appeal
because mr. Cosby could be facing ten
years maybe even more of imprisonment
but just because you're going to appeal
it doesn't mean you're going to be
successful on appeal I think this judge
was very fair to both sides he but he
let the defense put in for example
Margaret Jackson the prosecution
vigorously objected to that key defense
witness who obviously was not believed
he and and so I think doesn't doesn't
have a good chance on appeal is my view
do you think Bill Cosby should go to
jail I do think that he should serve
time in custody for this I mean this I
heard he was facing up to you could
possibly be facing up to 30 years well
that's true because ten years on each
count convicted on three count how much
time do you think he should spend well
you know I'll leave that up to the court
but there is going to be a sexually
violent predator assessment and and
we'll see but I do think that he should
spend time in custody he has hurt
he has damaged
he has changed the lives with so many of
the of these victims I know he's only a
trial for one but still I think he needs
to pay a price but the price he needs to
pay it has to do with his case but also
what kind of message does that send to
other women who might want to come
forward about taking on powerful men
well I think it says a great message and
it's a powerful man is not just a
celebrity
it could be somebody in the sports world
the religious world the business world
the educational world in your own family
someone who has taken advantage of his
position of power and betrayed the trust
that the person who is vulnerable and
less powerful has had in that person so
yes times they are a-changing and I'm
just very very happy about the
empowerment of women and the victory in
this case gloria allred thank you thank
you